good morning believe nation today's
message is live and breathe your craft
over to you Martin garrix when I was
like eight year old like mother I was
playing soccer and like the guys my team
didn't take it seriously I'm like oh you
want to be dj''q and I don't know IIIi
love producing and I loved eating so I
always kept on doing it practicing
trying to get better and how many hours
a day are you busy with music all the
hours that I'm not asleep select lately
I wake up also listening to music even I
music is everything to to live and
breathe it yeah so here's a guy Martin
garrix 20 years old listed to be the
number one DJ in the world how can you
achieve massive success in a short
amount of time you have to live and
breathe your craft too many people are
not prolific enough the people who are
the best in the world of what they do
they are prolific they practice they
repeat over and over and over and over
again in all fields how many times have
you seen the best athlete in whatever
sport being the first person to be at
the gym and the last person to leave
it's almost a cliche but it happens
every time Michael Jordan has the most
success Michael Jordan took the most we
throw practices took the most jump shot
practices he practiced he practice he
practiced the hone the natural talent
that he had I make it something
extraordinary
you can't Coast alone on talent if you
do you'll be mediocre at best you have
to be able to put in the work so here's
this guy 20 years old best DJ in the
world because he lives and he breathes
his crap you can get there in short
amount of time
if you hustle I told the story about
myself at the agency that I was at where
I was the worst storyteller it was the
worst person on camera and in a couple
months became the best just because I
was prolific not because I had skill or
talent but because I worked harder I was
making multiple videos a day
we're the people there had a hard time
finding time to make one video week if
you are only doing something one day a
week it's going to be really really hard
for you to get better at it and the
people who really live and breathe their
crafts are going to crush you they're
going to blow right past you and that
sucks if you're that person but it's
also great if you are the person who
live in brief cos you can pass people
very quickly we'll have a lot more
experience than you because you are
putting in the work to get better when I
was doing my bio video story I did it
3040 times I would do it three times a
day I would send it to my agent in the
morning he would give me feedback I'd do
it again at lunch you give me feedback I
do it again in the evening he would give
me feedback and I would make it better
and better and better and better and
better and those were long videos those
are like 20 minute videos it wasn't just
two minutes I did the whole thing each
time and I sent it to him and he watched
it and he gave me feedback and I did it
again and again I'm going through this
process with Lily Nile where we're
starting this project of unlocking Lily
to help turn her into a public speaker
we're doing the same thing her first
video she shot almost a hundred times
and she sent me a version and then I
said do it again it sent me another
version and do it again other version
she didn't send me because she knew it
wasn't very good she wants to redo it
tweaking tweaking tweaking tweak it and
still this is nothing compared to where
she's going to be able to be but she
hasn't quit her job yet she's working
full-time and she's still finding time
she said before going to work tomorrow
I'm going to go out so I'm gonna film it
when I get home tonight
before it gets dark and film another
version she's grinding she's hustling
she's going to get better faster you
have to live and breathe your craft if
you want to be the best in the world at
what you do you have to practice it's
not going to come from just doing
something one day a week so the question
today today is what is your craft
what are you beating on every single day
to try to get better so you could be one
of the best in the world at what you do
what is it leaving the comments below
cheers to find them I also want to give
a quick shout out to Rick Berwyn Rick
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book through one word I really
appreciate the support I hope you're
enjoying the book and you're applying
some of the lessons to your life into
your business thank you so much thank
you guys again for watching I hope you
have an amazing day I believe in you and
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events better
I like some spray so give me go
so what advice would you give purely in
an acting sense to yourself 30 40 years
ago same advice I gave myself 30 40
years old for those things get a job act
there are unfortunately those of us who
say well I want to be a star that's way
out there in the ether somewhere I want
be a working actor you can pull that off
so act work work I someone asked me what
and you're about to do it what would you
do if you weren't an active you didn't
make it as an actor what would you do I
have no idea I would act somewhere maybe
I'd be driving the cab maybe I've worked
in somebody's yard whatever I'm doing
I'm going to belong to somebody's little
theatre group I will act but I'll die if
I don't watch as many movies of as many
errors as you can when I was coming up
through the ranks there was a thing
called a Cinema Club in the seventies
where you threaded 16 millimeter film
and you projected it and I became
familiar with people that are important
to me like max of holes like Lauren
Hardy The Three Stooges
you became familiar with Renoir you
became familiar with everything from the
comedy to drama you can see preston
sturges
don't just limit yourself to what is out
there or the latest 10 top 10 on the
box-office
the methylamine tooled and imbibe live a
few mice because you're part of that
narrative eat anything even if it's not
film anymore you're part of that
narrative tradition and the second thing
I feel very important do not get wrapped
in the industry side of this that's what
I find really heartbreaking that people
are now a lot of times you're discussing
film with people that love film and it's
like you're listening to an agent from
an agency or a head of a studio they
know the grocer's they know who's doing
this I know it's not absolutely not
important the important thing is that
tradition you are going to belong to and
do not get caught on the other side stay
true to the other side that need you and
needs to access urgently but I got to
college I made this album several
members of my world it was an album I
did the same thing I locked myself in my
room for like all those college that was
it I just worked my to my room and kept
writing checks recording and I wasn't
great going into knowledge be able to
come back out
kind of like learn a little craft
[Music]
by the time organ our colleges look on
outliers by Malcolm Gladwell nobody's
really person anyway just examine the
book examine you feeling right and now
the Gladwell Texas point says it's not
about what the world was another level
Cavendish's war with about the hours
that you took ends about summer and he
says that allowed if you want to be a
master whatever and as you love to do if
you want to develop that craft with
utmost potential as you have to do is
work you have to work a lot you have to
edit hours of eases that if you put it
around 10,000 hours exit out one thing
that eventually people faster that fast
I don't know how I'll send a thousand
hours but every single time we step on
stage we can one step closer